captain while a great many people see
you as a hero there are some would
prefer the word vigilante you've
operated with unlimited power and no
supervision that's something the world
can no longer tolerate I know how much
buckling is here stay out of this one
please you saying you'll arrest me
there will be consequences
captain you seem a little defensive
claws been a long day if you can accept
limitations we're no better than that
guys
that's not the way I see it
sometimes I want to punch you in your
perfect teeth
what do we do we fight
you know it's about to happen
want to punch your way out of this
sorry time you know I wouldn't do this
fight any other choice
but he's my friend so was I
hey youtubers it's Charlie so Captain
America Civil War international trailer
a little bit of new footage just a great
way to spend your time trying to avoid
Star Wars spoilers that'd be great
subtext for Civil War Ironman wants to
spoil Star Wars Captain America ain't
havin it BAM
Avengers battle royale but the
interesting thing about this new footage
mostly makes it seem like Winter Soldier
lands on shields radar or the Avengers
radar because she'll doesn't really
exist anymore in black widows like yeah
we have to take this guy down I know
he's your friend cap but he has to
answer for what he did and of course cab
wants to redeem Bucky cuz he feels like
he was wrongly brainwashed and made to
do all these terrible things
assassinated all these people by Hydra
so really it seems like the role that
Winter Soldier plays in this movie is
just being the gasoline on the kindling
that is the sokovia accords like the
biggest point of contention the biggest
dispute is that cap doesn't want to go
under the rule of general Thunderbolt
Ross he feels like he's just as big a
villain as people in Hydra you know just
as bad so it's him against the US
government and their supporters
including at least half of the New
Avengers like Ironman war machine war
machine is always gonna side with the
government he's a lifelong military man
and then Winter Soldier lands on their
radar and cap tries to help him go on
the run so he officially becomes a
fugitive from the US government now the
other big thing that's also happened
recently is they've confirmed
spider-man's involvement obviously not
going to be as big as Black Panthers
involvement just because Marvel has like
that weird agreement with Sony where
they share the character but he is
definitely in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe
in fact there's this image that I put up
here of him visiting the set of Doctor
Strange now that doesn't mean that he's
in dr. strange or in that movie he's
probably just enjoying the perks of
being a teenager who is also an a-list
Marvel actor now hey can I visit the set
of this really awesome movie that you
guys are making you check it out why of
course you can that happens all the time
behind the scenes actors from other
studios will visit sets of movies if
they have friends working on them or
directors will invite other directors to
see early cuts of their film to give
them feedback James Gunn actually said
that he got to see an early cut of Star
Wars JJ Abrams was like hey please you
know come check this out
I mean they're both under the Disney
umbrella but JJ Abrams said that he was
just blown away by the uniqueness of
guardians of the galaxy so he wanted to
get James Gunn's perspective on what he
was doing with Star Wars I think you
know in the case of Tom Holland in the
case of spider-man visiting dr. strange
though it was pure
just for fun but don't completely rule
out like a post credit scene that throws
to spider-man because the first big
spider-man solo movie in the new Sony
trilogy is going to be coming out the
year after Doctor Strange comes out but
part of the arrangement with Marvel and
Sony sharing the spider-man character is
is that they help promote each other's
movies and in addition to sharing the
character in the actual movies so a lot
of people have been spreading rumors
that we will see some of the Avengers in
the spider-man solo film do you know
just minor cameos like think about how
much spider-man gets used to Captain
America Civil War whatever comes out I
mean obviously we haven't seen it yet
but then expect a couple of The Avengers
to get treated the same way in the solo
spider-man film I mean this is like the
Marvel shared universe and it includes
Sony now so it's gonna be awesome like
they're finally going to be able to
acknowledge that the Avengers exist in
spider-man films and the Marvel films
will get to acknowledge Peter Parker and
a lot of people have been asking about a
Doctor Strange teaser they they've
released some concept art but they
haven't released a full teaser yet
continuing through phase 3 we introduced
Doctor Strange you need a spectacular
happy to portray this character in the
fact that Benedict Cumberbatch has
agreed to do this role is huge fronts
Benedict he's got an incredibly
complicated emotional structure going on
it's one of the things that's important
to us in telling a magical story is
keeping it grounded but still leaving
enough room to have really cool and
unique visual ideas to explore
what you can expect from this Doctor
Strange movie is a mind trip action film
how do you put that on a screen within
this cinematic universe that is you know
one of the primary goals of that movie
the reason you don't see a lot of Doctor
Strange stuff happening right now is
because they're so busy promoted like
they just started promoting civil war so
they're mostly focused on that but let
me know in the comments below how do you
want to see spider-man used in Captain
America Civil War and the other Marvel
films civil war is really just the
beginning they're gonna be making
spider-man films with Tom Holland for at
least the next seven to eight years
depending on how fast they make the
sequels for the new trilogy so he is
definitely going to come back and future
Marvel films and I know everyone's
wondering about Star Wars spoiler watch
don't worry I'm gonna be posting my
non-spoilery review for Star Wars
Thursday night so it's still gonna be a
little while and then I'll post a
separate spoilery Easter Egg video at
least like a couple of days after that
so there's gonna be a ton of Star Wars
stuff this weekend be sure to subscribe
to get it all I'm still doing Star Wars
giveaway so just watch like my most
recent Star Wars video I'll put a link
in the description to learn all about
that and there is some new Batman V
Superman footage so I'll totally do a
video for that next so you don't have to
worry too much about Star Wars spoilers
there's still a ton other really cool
stuff that's happening to get pumped
about especially Deadpool the twelve
days of Deadpool is still going on so I
will try to do some new Deadpool
tomorrow
in case you guys haven't seen it I
posted a Star Wars Episode 7 lightsaber
fight behind the scenes video yesterday
you can click here to watch that and you
can click here to learn all about the
twelve days of Deadpool thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight
you